median coming in at stage is hilarious
ease down from New York City as well and
he has over 100 followers on Facebook
pretty impressive
please give a warm welcome to Hans Kim
everybody ever hugged me
[Applause]
[Music]
good to be here guys how you guys doing
well okay I think I'm doing better than
you I'm gonna be here my name is Hans
Kim and I am biologically a male so take
that dad science says you're wrong
I am biologically male but my bullies
identified me as a [ __ ] you can say I'm
very gender fluid my pronouns are horse
face and small [ __ ] I have a lot of
confidence right now let's probably why
respect me so much I think confidence is
very important because without
confidence stupid people would have no
idea for to pay attention to here okay
that guys making strong noises let's
follow that guy yeah and those are
called elections my name is hans kim
that's my real name my parents named me
hans because it didn't want kids at
school to make fun of me for having an
asian name so they gave me a german one
instead foolproof planet flew right
under the radar
then no idea I was Asian
I love being named Hans Kim I think
that's a funny name but I think it's
even funnier that tanner is a white
person's name ten isn't what you want
[ __ ] it should be like hey this
is my Mexican friend Tanner that's what
black from tannest Suffolk's true
[Music]
you know love the stand-up comedy but
sometimes I wish I was a painter because
I've never been painting a picture
another canvas be like bit drawn
something Asian never happens on a
painting it's very confusing language
English especially the sayings I hope
you can understand my English and it's
study have been in high school but I
don't understand all the sings in
English they say in prison don't drop
the soap
that's not even helpful it should be
don't pick up the soap they could drop
this myself as you want
it's the bending over where they really
get you if you don't drop this up you're
still gonna get raped just have really
clean hands all that happens what were
these rape is like I want to get that
kid but I never wrote so so
doesn't have a butthole I I don't I
don't like cops that much I'm pretty
badass like that you think big cops have
a hand fetish that's why they're always
like hey let me see your hands
nice they'll make the touch
let the butter but it's just getting off
on us now that's so rude you know what
they say in airports if you see
something suspicious say something
suspicious I saw an unattended package I
was like no better it dead great he's
very dreamy they were a little
suspicious there was a there's a sign in
my neighborhood it says 20 miles per
hour when children are present but what
if the children are dwelling in the past
then how fast we're driving I loved in
debts I think imminent or my favorite
punctuation mark because they're very
encouraging like hey come on buddy you
can do it look I'll get your head start
well if you halfway to the first line
already here you were a reader thanks
indents are so nice
anyways I saw a YouTube video or Tony
Hawk was like I used to keep boarding to
express my emotions but I've never
needed a skateboard to do that you know
I've never been arguing with the next
have been like a bully on my skateboard
I can show you I really feel when you
talk to your ex it makes me feel like
this just have a feel I drew a graph on
my skateboard I I'm not a homophobe you
know a lot of people might think that I
am or something I don't know anyways
next joke it's about me being homophobic
I was talking to this dude he was like
dude we're so lucky we're not gay can
you imagine if most of the gender we
were attracted to wasn't attracted to
his back and I was like whoa can't even
imagine
it was cry all the time those losers I
don't understand what people will say
it's Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve
right I don't understand that because
Adam and Eve were not even a good couple
good clean okay first of all they
disobeyed God and they had a fruit they
weren't supposed to eat which is kind of
gay
they raised Cain and Abel and Cain
murdered Abel or I take it panting
question people raised a murderer is
there a role model there are only three
other people on earth
you killed a quarter of the world's
population this [ __ ] just move up you
got the whole world
there's startup his [ __ ] together Jesus
I am not gay though I am a pretty
heterosexual as [ __ ] I don't think I
could ever [ __ ] a dude sorry sir yeah
I've never looked at a beautiful woman
it was like wow she's gorgeous but is
there a version of her that's bigger and
hairier and that's less kindness
a lot of put that in my bottle never
happened straightest [ __ ]
please blamed me why that doesn't I am
single
I have yet to meet my soul mate I'm
beginning today maybe it's her fault she
needs to get out more
she seems like a loser I think I could
do better I think women are very
beautiful and I creep them out a lot
because I started them and all of them
and it's a crime they have rights now
fellas keep up but it's very hard for me
to not creep women out because to me a
woman is like a beautiful sunset that
can yell at you like a balance side that
can call the cops
you can't take a picture you kind of
want to go I get a lot of advice for my
friends that I dude you don't learn how
to talk to women maybe or maybe women
should learn how to listen to Hans why
don't you want to hear about the Federal
Reserve it's very complex there's a lot
going on there this is one lady with
like did you know that my vagina is a 3d
printer because it can make a baby I was
like technically incorrect your womb is
the duty printer your vagina is the tray
it's not even a very good 3d printer
here it's one thing with lots of errors
takes nine months to print and the whole
time it's printing it's complaining move
is the saying I did not say any trays
that night
I am sapiosexual so I'm looking for a
woman who is interested in mental
exercises like finding me attractive
when we said the puzzles you know oh
they [ __ ] you worried that tonight okay
I can figure this up it's all for X I
hate it when women called me a premature
ejaculator okay first of all premature
to who I can't write at the perfect time
when it felt amazing takes maturity do
not please yourself
I do love the ladies I think it's a good
thing that women get burned because I
feel like a been gear burns we'd be like
brillo I think you so much protein and
creatine there my pregnancy
this baby's like 27 pounds already bro
check out a six-pack of ultrasound those
gains in the first trimester I am kind
of a nerd I don't like people who work
out all the time
because this is 2020 we don't even need
lives anymore well in the gym working
out there's a nerd in a basement
clearing out your bank account
why don't you go study some math so you
stop getting [ __ ] out BOGO deals at
GNC did you do it idea what I do is I
work overtime and I buy a forklift and
mathematically I'm just as sexy as you
are that's the best way to be sex
mathematically please ladies not all at
once
calm down over there I am agent you know
which is unfortunate because I'm an
Asian man you know I hope these Asian
women are beautiful in that occasion men
are beautiful which just doesn't even
make any sense I mean how do you think
Asian women are created hello
me [ __ ] that's a I'm a crucial part
of the sexy process please stop trying
to skip me if you have sex with me our
children will be very beautiful
half of them the other half will be
great engineers in that supporting 2i I
know what I look like but I'm not that
into anime which is unfortunate because
the only women were attracted to me
they're pretty into anime it's like
their whole thing I forgot a resting
anime face I'm constantly cosplay I'm on
a day like oh very interesting just a
little an anime for you you know it's
hard being Asian a lot of people make
fun of us because we dogs which I
understand can be very shocking because
in America dogs are treated like family
members but in Asia we treat our family
members like family members
while a nation in the corner then you'll
know you know this is very little
tradition we have where instead of
buying an animal we love our grandma
should everyone better in Asia unless
their baby girl which gets you throw
them in the river everyone else would
you really well you know I am Asian
North another's country of Chinese I'm
from a province in china called south
korea
it's right next to the Japan province I
don't understand people who are racist
to agents they're like you know you know
what I hate these people who are kind
and respectful and keep to themselves
sorry sorry we'll play I mean it's gonna
be hard to avoid this we make a lot of
cards and stuff good luck finding an
affordable car literally hard to
contribute one of my Asian friends make
fun of me because I like to eat General
Tso's chicken
they're like isn't General Tso's chicken
just a shitty Americanized version of
something authentically Asian like yeah
but so am i my favorite movies rush hour
3 Reaper Christian in her household as
Asian people which is kind of weird
because the people read the Bible the
name is even know that Asia's existed I
[Music]
couldn't even drop us a line
hey James great job in inventing the
fire was really kind of you guys duck to
the Jews my favorites I am an atheist
now because I'm not a kindergarten and
have an internet connection I think it'd
be stressful to have a worldview that
can be destroyed by facts
I like walking down the street oh look
apostle okay I guess they could have
been blowing dudes it's all time I am a
son of immigrants and I don't understand
people who want everyone to speak
English because they're never the type
of people that want to have a
conversation with a foreigner did never
like learn is being English so I can
learn more about Diwali the festival of
lights those language barriers killing
me I don't understand that you want
everyone on this bus to be able to
communicate with you gross
you speak Hungarian and go over there
I'm American I don't understand people
who blame immigrants for their problems
or like you know is taking all my money
these people with less money than me
they've got my money what about the
people what the money they took your
money
you think Mexican people before they go
to America they're friends like oh
you're going to America you know you can
drink the shower water over there
gonna be buddy I of course am NOT a
racist I'm a minority how could I be
impossible I don't even see race only
smell it I mean I hate people too I just
get to know them first you hear people
for their skin I hate you move their
souls I think I'm a white pride can be a
good thing but I think a lot of people
do it incorrectly
they're always into like the Nazis and
the Confederate flag they're never into
building a castle or yodeling that's not
white pride that's racism it happens to
be a white tape the Jews I can do that
too but it up I'm a comedian I was on a
plane once and I saw it dude reading a
book in Arabic which kind of freaked me
out but then I saw him pull the corner
of the page and put the book away and I
was like oh thank god he's got future
plans at foreign not a racist I'm a big
fan of the Black Panther movie I thought
that was a great movie because it gave
blind children and hero they could look
up to and not just someone like Marlon
King jr. Malcolm X or Harriet Tubman or
Rosa Parks if they're good Marshall or
Nelson Mandela or Kody ihnat Desmond
Tutu
Denzel Washington Muhammad Ali Jackie
Robinson Obama Oprah Tupac baby now
there is a fake person that doesn't like
a cat congratulations
I'm just jealous what are they going to
come out with the yellow Panda I have a
sister who just got back from a mission
trip if you don't know that as a mission
trip is when Americans go to their gold
countries to get new profile pictures
it's not those likes I I think it's
weird that I'm autistic I think that's
very strange it sucks being autistic
because it's the only disease that you
could diagnose in a bar no one's ever
like oh hey this guy talks like he has
non-hodgkins lymphoma let's go to the
jägerbombs with them people are like
yeah you're book smart but I'm street
smart
you're smart in a way that's not
measurable or comparable
I can read it for you you're not smart
you're criminal that's called aggravated
assault stop hitting me it hurts a Billy
when white people say that there's
street smart it usually means that
they're good at ignoring minorities in
public don't make eye contact to me I'm
gonna make a human connection
I think the Confederate flag is a very
offensive because that's like if your
wife came up to you it was like hey
remember that time I go to my huge
argument and I trying to divorce you
yeah I'm only proud at the time the
represents Who I am as a person so I got
a divorce papers tattooed on my chest
I I love riding the subway the subway
school but I hate it when homeless
people beg for change on the subway so
what I usually do is I switch cars that
way I can sing unto them over and over
again so I'm difficult so it's two cars
in front of them and do their whole act
before they get there
only make them thick on their feet this
time I I love hopping the turnstiles
I love subway stations because that's a
perfect crime that's like robbing a bank
and they provide you with the getaway
driver well let's give the scene in the
corner I was I was on an escalator and
then I was walking up the escalator and
subdued was like dude why do people walk
up escalators that doesn't make any
sense because but then I didn't hear the
rest of that sentence because I was
covering so much [ __ ] distance left
in the dust yeah that's my destination
do you think people who play their music
out loud on speakers who think those
people have ever cross paths with each
other
you've never been walking around like
man that's annoying
[Music]
wait a minute amended um I am a drug
user I love drugs I don't understand
sober people
you're gonna rely on your day to make
you happy Jesus Christ take some control
back in your life I don't understand
these people collide aren't you afraid
of having a bad trip and changing your
brain forever you know what else is
going to change your brain forever your
mom dying
that happens to sober people too so if I
can handle my mom being dead to the rest
of my life I think I can handle aliens
for a day I'll drink some water figure
it out hug your mom's oh I'm afraid my
jokes did not kill any of your mother's
I was talking to this guy who told me he
was a drug addict and he was like dude
you have no idea what it's like to be a
drug addict and I was like I know if
only you guys would write books or
movies or TV shows or paint paint and
sing songs but you know it's wrong I
there's always in the corner other party
to keep it to themselves
what are you really bookworms tell a
long boring story why don't you
I love rednecks rednecks are cool
because they could survive in any
wilderness situation that you put them
in except in a situation where everyone
has equal rights that kind of [ __ ]
them up you can survive in a swamp with
an alligator and making a living on
cul-de-sac with a minority
have you tried smiling I don't
understand people who say make America
great again because that means that the
hate where we got now so they want to go
back to the past but if you go back to
the past we're just gonna get this again
that's the exact recipe for this thing
you hate so much that's like being like
I hate cakes let's go back to the time
we mix the flour with the egg and put it
on then I I don't think everyone who's
patriotic is stupid but I do think
everyone who's stupid is gonna be a
little patriotic because if you got
nothing good going on in your life
you're gonna be like well at least I'm
here so if you're gonna tell I'm Andrew
yang supporter
I'm in the yang gang okay can't wait til
we all live in a yang stirrers paradise
would be like what big yang baby yeah
I'm a gangbanger you know bang bang bang
well forget I I'm not a communist
but I do support any policies and
Republicans consider communism which is
whatever two or more people gather to do
something nice I like how Americans will
say communism never works as if we
didn't spend billions of dollars and
kill millions of people to make sure it
wouldn't work remember the war in
Vietnam we're pretty anal about it not
work in confidence it never works
because whenever people control the
means of production their democratically
on with the leaders mysteriously dying
and the small rubble group finds an
automatic weapon somehow and look
they're making themselves
why are you subjugating yourself where
you said you're gonna hear so are you
saying it yourself I think capitalism is
great you know if you want to do it just
don't make everyone play your stupid
game
I like fortnight I don't make a grandma
play and take away our house or she
loses
it was on the way over here and I
realized that there's a lot more trans
people than we even know about like I
was on the way over here and I saw a
bicyclist who identified as an
automobile got a call Kia now all right
that's what that guy's very much
[Applause]
[Music]
let's give everybody even Oprah hi
[Applause]